twitter zerstört unsere beziehung ein
neuer server anzug schutz vor angriffen
und wie public viewing richtig geht das
sind drei der themen jetzt in den kick
zum top 5 news aus dem pixum de blog
verbrennungsgefahr uv strahlung erreicht
höchstwert in den bolivianischen anden
wurde ein neuer höchstwert der uv
strahlung gemessen
jetzt bekannt wurde erreichte im
dezember 2003 die strahlung den uv-index
43 3 um das einordnen zu können in
deutschland treten im sommer werte
zwischen 8 und 9 auf atv index 8 ist ein
aufenthalt im freien bedenklich kritisch
wird es laut uwe meister vom richard
assmann auf santorin des deutschen
wetterdienstes ab dem wert 11 die mass
höhe der zenit stand der sonne und eine
dünnere ozonschicht bewirkten die
gemessenen extremwerte damit wurden
früher gemessene höchstwerte nahezu
verdoppelt die forscher verweisen nun
auf modelle demzufolge die ozonschicht
über den tropen durch den klimawandel
abnehmen wird
deshalb rechnen sie mit weiteren
extremen werden
die studie wird übrigens jetzt erst
veröffentlicht da kontrollmessung und
reise komplikation die forschungsarbeit
bremst später zerstört beziehungen eine
intensive nutzung des
kurznachrichtendienstes twitter
beeinflusst das liebesleben das hat der
forscher rasselt clayton in einer
befragung von twitter-nutzern
festgestellt er befragte rund 600
twitterer nach ihrer aktivität auf
twitter und eventuellen
beziehungsproblemen dabei kam heraus
dass häufiger streit und trennung in
einer beziehung durch häufiges twittern
verursacht werden
das hört nämlich zu streit und
konflikten in der beziehung die folge
sind untreue trennung und scheidung
wir haben denn wie moore und ashton
kutcher offenbar zu viel getwittert
schon im vergangenen jahr gab es
übrigens eine studie von russell treten
darin untersuchte er zusammenhänge
zwischen beziehungsproblemen und dem
sozialen netzwerk facebook das ergebnis
war ähnlich auch unter starker
facebook-nutzung leiden beziehungen
so geht fußball schauen am sonntag ist
es soweit die deutsche
nationalmannschaft steht im finale der
fußball weltmeisterschaft 2014 in
brasilien gegen argentinien erwarten wir
natürlich in heißes spiel und deshalb
einige tipps von mir wie ihr das public
viewing oder wo sonst immer ihr auch
seit ohne probleme über steht viel
trinken auf dem platz verlieren die
spieler ja eine menge flüssigkeit ihr
seht was immer die trinken eine menge
und das gilt aber auch für zuschauer und
deshalb sind optimal isotonische
getränke saftschorlen oder einfach
wasser vorsicht bei bier
alkohol ist in kombination mit großer
hitze gefährlich weil der schlechter vom
körper verarbeitet werden kann
sonnenschutz ist wichtig die haut sollte
mit sonnencreme geschützt werden und
damit den kühlen kopf bewahrt sollte
nicht nur die deutsche
nationalmannschaft gut spielen sondern
ihr solltet auch eine helle
kopfbedeckung tragen
ihr sollt auf energy drinks am besten
verzichten weil das viele koffein zu
krampfanfällen führen kann und zusammen
mit alkohol ist noch schlechter
und ja wenn ihr diese tipps beachtet
dann gibt es einen unterhaltsamen
fernsehabend freuen wir uns also auf ein
spannendes finale
die jungs sollen dem programm mal nach
hause bringen ich durch die daumen und
meint übrigens ist 3 zu 1 und ihr könnt
mit tippen ich verlosen nämlich zwei
tickets für die video days unter den
richtigen antworten hier in den
kommentaren von jedem account wird nur
einen tipp berücksichtigt und das
natürlich auch nur bis zum spielbeginn
ich drücke den baum noch ein fußball
thema deutsche nationalmannschaft eisbad
gegen muskelkater eisbader nach großen
anstrengungen helfen gegen muskelkater
das hat der mannschaftsarzt der
deutschen nationalelf herausgefunden
nach dem anstrengenden achtelfinale
gegen algerien wollte per mertesacker ja
unbedingt schnell in die sonne
vielleicht auch um seinen kopf
abzukühlen nach einem etwas witziges
interview mit einem reporter des zdf
die meyer seit 2003 mannschaftsarzt der
deutschen nationalmannschaft der hat
herausgefunden dass kälte
als vorbeugung gegen muskelkater hilft
dazu behandelte er in einer studie
sportler an einem bein
mit kalten bädern das andere leser in
ruhe und das ergebnis die gekühlten
muskeln regenerierten besser als die
unbehandelten dennoch warnte maier vor
zu häufiger anwendung das kann nämlich
den trainingseffekt erheblich
beeinträchtigen 12 anzug schutz vor
angriffen
zwei australier haben einen surfern zug
entwickelt der vor hai attacken schützen
soll
das streifenmuster des anzugs ihre tiere
die sich trotz ihrer besonders
ausgeprägten sinnesorgane mit den augen
orientieren
die veränderte reflektion des lichts
macht surfer für sie nahezu unsichtbar
einen ähnlichen anzug gibt es auch für
taucher in zusammenarbeit mit dem
erfinder craig anderson und der
university of western australia hat
hämisch jolly die shark attack
mitigation systems kurz sams entwickelt
für etwa 250 dollar können surfer den
anzug erwerben eine lohnende investition
meinen die entwickler der anzug ist
allerdings keine rüstung
deshalb gilt trotz schutz werden haie
gesichtet umgehend das wasser verlassen
und noch ein thema denkt superhelden
können wir alle genies werden
hier klicken für das video und nichts
verpassen bei gigs und dafür schaut
bitte an abo feed und aktiviert klicks
und news gibt es hier oben im pixum blog
die linkswähler auch in der video
beschreibung und wenn er das video bis
hierher geschafft habt dann auf jeden
fall abonnieren ist sehr kostenlos bis
zum nächsten mal bis dann bleibt dran